よろしくお願いします
今日は最後のお話で 業からの脱出するというテーマでございます
今日の話はそんなに難しくないと思いますけど
このずっと四回分けてね
人間というのはどうすれば幸福になるかとかね
まあいいことって何ですかとかね
そういうふうな傾向で話してきましたけど
で 本当の心理の状態っていうのは
聞いたらだいたい人間っていうのはすごい怖くなるんです
で 自分というものはね
どのようなものかしっかりとはっきりと見ると
もう誰でも恐ろしく ものすごく怖くなるということは事実なんです
ですから このなかなか真実そのまま言いにくいっていうことはあるんです
だから いくら真実だと思っても
言って聞く人がそこで大変混乱して怖くなって
精神的におかしくなるんだったらね
まあまあそれほど意味がないと
お釈迦様もこの悟ってすぐ何一つもしゃべらないと決めちゃったんですね
もう喋っても意味がないんだと
で それで後でまた考えて
やっぱり説法しますということになりましたけど
かなり苦労したんですね
説法するして人々を説得するためには
それにお釈迦様の弟子たちっていうのは
ものすごい頭の良い人々ばっかりで
また長い間いろんな宗教やらいろんなことを探求して研究して修行していた
もう優れた人々で選び抜かれた人々ですから
その人々の間でも真理を語るということは大変な仕事でしたしね
世の中にあるのはほとんどではなくて
全部嘘ばっかりなんですね
ごまかしだけで人間っていうのは生きているんですね
褒めてほしくて で まああまりまあ悪いことは言わないと
で ただ機嫌取るというふうな感じで
世の中で人間っていうのはよく喋ってるんですね
だから自分の気持ちにああ
よく合うんだと この話はと
その話によく乗っていくと
それはもうもともと間違ってるんですね
例えば我々私たちは人の話を聞いたところで
よくも気に入ったと よく納得いきましたと
だから私はその人の言う通りにすると言っても
そこになんか落とし穴あるんですね
もともと自分がそう思っていたんだから気に入ったんです
ですから 結局何も聞いてないんです
ただ自分の頭の中整理しただけかもしれませんし
ですから 新しい情報っていうのは人間の頭に入るか入らないか
僕はずっと私も一人で悩んで考えてたんだけどね
あなた言ってることはよくわかりますよと言った途端
あれおかしいんじゃないかなと
わかるんだったら あんた最初からそれ知ってるんじゃないかと
最初から知ってるんだったら
別に私は何も言ったことにならないんだと
ということで 世の中で私たちはやっぱりこの人間の機嫌を取ろうと思ってね
人間聞きたいことばっかり喋ってるんですね
ということは 全然知識を与えてないということのマスコミと同じなんですね
人々聞きたいものだけ選んで流しちゃうんです
いろんなメディアで 本当に世の中で何が起きてるんですか？それを我々はどうするべきかということは言わない
そういう記事なんか誰も読まない
ただ 自分の面白がって自分聞きたがっているものだけ聞くと
そういうのは人間の心のある状況で
あの まあ煩悩といえば煩悩なんですけどね
そのような話は事実ではないし
もし人が事実を喋ると
その人を社会から追い出すんです
これは昔だけじゃなく今でも同じことなんです
ガリレオさんなんか殺した
それは昔です 今はやらないと
そうじゃないんです 今でも事実喋っちゃったら
その人その社会から追い出すんです
あんた方はみんなと同じ
みんな言ってることをやりなさいとという話は普通のことで
みんなと同じ泥の沼に入っちゃって
もう目が見えなくて死ぬんだったら
まあよくできた人やと
そこから立ち上がろうとすると
その人はもうおかしいんだと言われるんですね
ですから まあそういうことで
仏教もはっきり誰も喋れないんですね
嘘ばっかり言ってるんです
そういうことで まあ本当に困ったもんなんですね
事実はどうしても言いにくくなっているし
まあ命知らず まあ怖いものを知らないとという感じで喋らなくちゃいけないんです
まあそれはそれを置いておいて
まあ言いたがっているのは
この本当の存在っていうのはそんなに面白いものではないと
恐ろしいものだと まあ一つ霊で考えてみましょう
で まあ仏教の話にやはり入りますけど
あの仏教ではね 人の生命を奪う奪ってはいけないと
それは悪いことだと 悪いことですと
で 言ってるんですね 五劫の中で悪業というかね
不善というんですね 殺生っていうのは
で 理由は私は生きていきたいんだから
他の人々もまた同じく生きてきたいんですね
で 私に何の権利もないんですね
他の人の生命に対して
で 何のも権利ない では
自分は全然他の生命より偉いわけじゃないんです
事実見ると自分が他の生命から支えられてるんですね
生かされてるんですね
それですから もう話にならないんです
殺生はいくら理由があっても認めることはできないんですね
仏教では あなた 他の生命に支えられて生きてきて
その生命の一人でも殺す権利はまるっきりないということで
たとえ微生物にしたっても
私たちを大変命を助けてくれてるんですからね
殺す権利はないんです
じゃあそこで話を終わって
で 我々は生きるということで何やってるんですかね
私は生きてますと 言って何やってるんですかと見ると
ずっと他の生命に邪魔するか
他の生命殺してるかと
それで生きていると言うんです
どれぐらいの今までね
この体を養うためにどれぐらいの生命を食べてきたかというと
植物にしたっても生きるものだから
人間にはかわいそうにこの石とかね
土とか食べられないんです
食べたら死んじゃうんです
鉄とかね 体に鉄分必要です
これも鉄の鉄分食べてそのままこういうものとかね
取って食べればいいでしょうに
で 食べられないんですね
鉄が入ってる生命食べなくちゃいけないんですね
体にカルシウム欲しいんだったら
もういくらでもカルシウムあるでしょうね
もう石の形で食べればいいんだけど
それでダメなんですね
カルシウム入ってる植物か動物を食べなくちゃいけなくなってるんですね
体はそういうふうにできてるんです
ですから こんなに威張れるんですかっと
生きてるんだとか何とかとか
単なる殺生ばっかしでしょうね
1 秒 1 秒生きていたっても
で 虎とね 熊と何が違うんですか？人間と
毛がないぐらいかな で
ただ他人を殺して食べてるんで
ですから その中でどうやってごまかしよるんですかね
だからもう世の中ほとんどごまかしが尊い命ですよとか
どこら辺尊いかな どんな角度で人間の命尊いですかね
全然ないんです ただ恐ろしいだけ
で ライオンでも虎でもね
獲物を取りたい場合は
お腹が空いた なんか食べたいなと思って
あっちこっち見て まあ走れない
あるいは病気になってる
怪我しているとか それぐらいの
まあもう死にそこそこの獲物を取って食べてるんですね
誰でも一度は見たことないでしょ
ライオン ライオンは鹿を飼ってるんだと
大きな檻を作って そこで餌をあげて鹿を飼ってるんだと
鹿の牧場を作ってるんだと
そこでまあ餌を食べたい時は牧場に行って一匹を取って食べると
そんなことやらないんですね
人間以外は 人間はもう殺傷するだけじゃなくて
もう牧場やらあだこだとか
もう鶏とかなんとかとか
みんなもう檻に入れてもう逃げられないんですね
そこまで恐ろしいんです
そこで海の魚にしたって
もうあの取る もう残酷なことっていうのは
全然もう同等の量で戦わないんですね
魚は魚を食べてるんだけど
もうお互いに戦って食べてるんです
逃げられるものは逃げてもいいと
人間どうですかね 大きな網をかけて
それから逃げられないようにして
あるいは養殖まででもして
で だからあんまりも恐ろしいんですね
ですから まあそれは事実それはそれは喋らない
考えるともしない どれほど恐ろしいことをやってるんですかと
で それからまあ我々のじゃあ経済学って何ですかね
経済活動しているんだとかね
現代社会はえらい発展しているんだと
あれなんですかね 弱い者いじめでしょうね
単なる 弱い人の財産をいかに奪うかという学問なんです
だからその角度でも物事を見てほしいんです
ただもうね ごまかしばっかしでね
まあなんて言いますかね
あの銀紙ばっかり貼っても銀にならないんです
段ボール箱に銀紙を貼るんだと
だからこれは銀の箱ですよと言ったら
そうはならないんです
経済学にしたっても 単なる弱い者いじめの学問であって
だから弱い人はやられちゃうんです
競争で そこで正しく修行するわけじゃなくてね
もうなんか発見したら
それは秘密だと 見せませんと
あるいは特許をなんか決めちゃって
他の人にそれはもう排除して
自分が儲かってるんですね
なんか自分が発見したら
みんなにどうぞ出てきてください
みんなでこれで使って幸福になりましょうという概念
まるっきりないでしょうね
ですから 今最近なんですか
この植物まで DNA なんとかね
遺伝改良して作ろうと思ってるでしょうし
今まではどんな人でも何か種を植えてね
生活してご飯何か食べていたんだけど
これからはできないんです
これからまあ 遺伝研究して種開発しちゃったら
みんなそういう工場で会社から買わなくちゃいけないんです
もし隠れてでもどこかでそういう同じものを作っちゃったら
裁判でもすごいお金払わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
そんなものは科学と言いますけどね
経済学と言いますけど
まあちょっと客観的に見ると
単なる弱い者いじめと泥棒しか何も私には見えませんね
我々がやっている歴史学って何ですかね
一番恐ろしい人間の話ばっかりでしょう
一般人の話は一つもないでしょうね
生きてる間も人を抑えて
人を搾取して 人を殺したりしてね
で 生活した連中のもう物語でしょうね
一般人の話 歴史に出ているんですか？何も本当に頑張って国を支えたかった人々が
どんな国にも歴史もそれ入ってないんです
戦う連中の名前あるんだけど
その戦う人々にご飯作って食べさせてる人々の名前全然ないんでしょう
人殺しに行くって その人はご飯食べなきゃどうやって人殺すんですかね
その人々のためにご飯作った人々
ない 歴史に 古墳とかあだこだとか発掘するでしょう ４０００
年前の古墳が 全然面白くないんです
あのもの それ一番恐ろしいとこ死んでも自分のまあここに居たよと言いたくて
今日も電車である人がね
あの刀なんか入ってる
なんか研究本みたいなものを見ていたんだけど
くっだらないことをやるんだなと思ったんだけどね
まあもしかすると目白で降りたんだから
そこら辺の大学の人かもしれませんだけどね
ホウレンソウでも植えた方がもっといいんじゃないかなと思ったんだけどね
そこでああいう写真撮って
まあ顕微鏡で見て レントゲンで撮って
これはこうだ これは本物だ
これは何々人のああだこうだとか
何のためにですね あんなことは
人殺しの道具でありますけど
で やっぱり我々作っている社会っていうのはそんなような社会なんです
人間尊いというか もう人間っていうのはもう人間ほど怖いものはないんですね
この存在の中で で 見たことがありますかね
人間見たらどんな動物も逃げるでしょう
牛なんか見たら 牛の背中に鳥が止まってるんです
鳥が止まって鼻の中に入ってるあのノミとかね
平気でもう取って食べてるんです
私も自分の肩に鳥なんか取って止まってほしいんだけどね
まあちょっと本を出すたっても
まあそれぐらい我慢しますよ
全然止まってくれませんね
取ると逃げる 他の動物もそうなんです
どうしても逃げられない場合は攻撃します
それものすごく怖くなっちゃって
あ しまったと ここで戦わなくちゃということでも
無意味に人を殺すのは
無意味に同じ民衆を殺すのは
同じ民衆ではなくて 同じスペシーズ
同じ種類を自分同じ種類を殺すのはどんな動物ですかね
人間だけでしょ 無意味に
そこで世の中見てみましょう
人殺しの目的は何ですかね
私たちはAという宗教を信じているんだから
この人々は他の宗教を信じているんですよと BCDEF
という だから殺してやりましょうと
そんなもんでしょうに
この国はこの島はこの国のものだよと
いいえ 隣の国 いいえ 私のものだよと
どうでもいいんだから
無人島だから それもそういうことに戦争して人殺すでしょうに
今あまりにも危なくて戦争できないんですね
昔はそれほど危なくなかったんだから戦争したんだけどね
まあ小さな小さなね まあ足
まあ一人の人間立ったらそれで終わるぐらいの小さな島とかあるんですけど
それにまあ韓国やら中国やら台湾やら日本やら
いえ 私のもの 私のものだと
ある人 私に聞いた その場合どうすればいい？僕は爆弾持って行って爆弾かければそれでいいんですよと
それは答えですよと 誰のものでもないんだと
で まあ中国はインドまで
インドの土地もまあチベットまで取ったり
チベット中国のものやとかね
そういうものをね 人は
自分の国であっても他人民族という人々がいて
自分たちの国が欲しいんだと
今まで国でいたんだから
その通りにいればいいのに
でも国民を殺してるんです
八十パーセントの人口をずっともう毎日何人か殺されるんです
だからまあ 何のために殺してるんですかというと
あんまりくだらない目的でしょうね
宗教とか政治的な考え方とか
あるいは同じ民族であっても
北朝鮮と韓国でしょう
同じ韓国人でしょうね
北に住んでるんだからでも見たらもう殺しちゃうんです
だけど それは我々生きてる社会なんですね
それは人間が自分の心で作っている社会なんですね
そこに神も仏も何もないんです
だから我々は人間っていうのはもうあんまりもう巨大な無明で巨大な幻覚の中できてるんです
で 私は政治学の概念 一行二行ぐらいは勉強していたんだけど
まあこのいろいろ昔のね
政治学学者たちが政府って何ですかと大っ手なに定義すると
それはもう一つ この何て言いますか
コントラクト理論 契約
神とある人間が契約を立てているんだと
その人は王であって その人はまあ国民をコントロールするんだと
あれで学者っているんですかね
政治 ああいう風な定義作ってるんですね
またあの意見は良くないんだと
政府っていうのは国民とある人の契約だよと
政治に際してなんでこういうことを考えたんですか？と
僕は勉強する時は お釈迦様が考えた政治学は何ですかという
我々にちょっとした質問があって
研究しなくちゃいけなくなって
そこで お釈迦様が言っているのは
ストーリーを言ってるんですね
昔々政治はなかったと
人間には自分の土地というものはなかった
ただ物語ですけどね で
食べたい時はみんな外へ行って
米を取って  一日一日の分だけ取って
それで食べているんだと
という もう誰の土地ということではなかったと
そこでケチな人々が怠け者でケチな人々が出てきて
毎日行って この作物やらね
野菜やら取るのは面倒くさいんですよと
二日分ぐらい持っていこうと
二日分取っちゃったんだと
そこで他の人々はこれはいい考え方で
私も三日分取りますよと
もう一人  一週間分取りますよと思っていると
取って取って このなんて家に置いておくようにしたんだと
それでケチが生まれたんだから
欲が生まれたんだから
あれなくなったんです
あまり取りすぎて それでまあ
一応土地を分けて農業するようになったって
そこでまたある人が自分でない他人の土地のものを取ったりしたんだと
それで泥棒も出てきたんだと
そこでも人間の欲望あって
お互いに汚いことをやるんだから
もうどうしようもなくなって
これ大変だと 我々お互いに殺し合いやってるんだと
これ良くないんだと だから誰かが我々をコントロールする人が必要ですよと思って
人間が見たら一応性格できている立派な人が見つけて
あなたは性格もよろしいし
ですからこの私たちは私の土地のものを取ったら
私はその人を殺そうとする
その人もまたかえって私を殺そうとする
そんなこと生き方はできないんだと
ですから あなた方は我々の問題はちゃんと解決しなさいと
トラブル起きちゃったらその代わりにあなた忙しくなるんだから
私たちは自分の収入の一部をあげますよと
そういうふうに初めての王様ができたんだと
で お釈迦様の考え方はあのストーリーですばらしく
私は思いますね だから美しい話じゃないんです
人間の汚さなんですね
そこから政治システムができたんだと
そこで最初の王様っていうのは
国民が選んだんだから
国民の使用人というかね
エンプロイーなんですね
エンプロイーって何でしたっけ
うん 雇われている人なんです
だから国民がえらいんです
でも お釈迦様の時代でも国民は偉くはなかったんです
ただ 奴隷みたいに王様にね
抑えられていたんだけども
お釈迦様はちらっとストーリーを作って
ご自分の意見を言ってるんです
偉いのは結局は本当は国民ではないかと
国民の雇われの主ではないか
雇われてる人ではないかと
そういうことで この仏教の立場から世の中を見ると
あんまり美しい絵を描けないんです
で 美しいものを知りたければ
普通の世の中のみんな言ってることを聞けばいいんです
なんでそういう話を言いますかというと
我々生きるということ自体
まあなんて無意味ですかと
なんて恐ろしいですかと考えてほしいんです
人を人ではなくて 他人を殺さずに生きていられますかと
他人にものすごい限りない邪魔をしないで生きていられますかね
我々はこの世の中で生まれたくて生まれたくて生まれたんだけど
どれぐらい自分の母親に迷惑かけたんですかね
私たちの子どもの時代っていうのは
まあまあ そんなに食べ物とかね
あった時でもないし 今も自分の食いがあるわけじゃないんだけど
で やっぱり自分も食べないで子供に食べさせちゃうんですね
母親っていうのは 朝から晩までもう一生懸命いろんなことをやってやって疲れてもうヘタヘタになってるのに
まああるものはまあ子供に分けてあげちゃうし
ですから  私ものすごい小さい時ね
もうたまにこの何か美味しいものとかね
なんかあったらやっぱり母親は食べないんですね
まあ適当にあるとみんなにちゃんと分けますけど
それで我々はすぐそれ全部食べて母親の分も狙っちゃうんです
で 何のことなくそれもまた子供に分けてあげちゃうと
自分も食べたいだろうと
まあ当たり前でしょうしね
ですから まあこういう風に大きくなったんです
恐ろしいことをして 残酷な生活をして
で 仏教ではいろんなストーリーあるんです
ストーリーでいきましょう
で この生きるということはどれほど怖いものかと
で お釈迦様の先世物語で
いわゆるお釈迦様は今世で生まれる前に
遠い昔 もういろんなところで生まれ変わって修行したというストーリーがストーリーまとめてあるんですね
まあえっと ストーリーがあるんです
で  まあそれはまあいろいろまあ問題あるストーリーもありますけど
で 一つのストーリーでお釈迦様はある国で
王様の一人息子で生まれたんだと
で 息子が生まれたところで
父親が大変喜んだ いや
跡継ぎが生まれたんだと
この国に で まあ自分が仕事をしている時でも
やっぱり子供を抱いたくなっちゃうんですね
そこで王様として国の裁判をやっている時
で まあ子供を抱いてきて
膝の上に座って笑って
で 人々の裁判を聞いているんです
だからその時はなんか泥棒した人々何人か捕まってきて
王様 この人々はこういうこういうところで泥棒して捕まりましたと
だから今風にこの まああなた
まあ何と言いますか 認めますかないかとかね
そういう質問ないんですね
昔は 弁護人は誰ですかとかね
そういうのは何もない
ああそう みんな打ち首にしなさい
何のことなく命令しちゃったんですね
そこでこの膝の上にいた子供がもう菩薩ですからね
単なる人間というよりはすごい感覚は鋭いし
ものすごくショック受けたやったんですね
だからいくらなんでも殺せという命令だから
それは悪いエネルギーだから
これこう感じちゃうんです
で すごいショック受けちゃったら
そのそこら辺にある神がいて
その神様 神様ではなくて
まあある まあ神ですね
で 子供は大変ショックを受けたということは分かって
ただ その神の過去生でその子供の母親でしたそうです
ですから もう一応今違うところに生まれていたとも
愛情はまだあるんですね
あれ 昔私の子供でしたと
今この子はない 大変怖がっているんだと
何とかしなくちゃいけないんだと
言って ちょっとこのこの落とし穴から抜ける方法を教えたんですね
なぜショック受けたんですかというと
この子供にあの超能力あったんですね
その瞬間で ショックでいきなり自分の過去を思い出したそうです
思い出したら 自分も遠い遠い昔
この国で王で生まれいたんだと
その時王様で堂々と仕事をして
もうものすごい長い間地獄で苦しんだんだと
また同じところで生まれ変わったんだと
またこれから私がまた父親が死んじゃったら
また王にならなくちゃいけないし
それで人の審判裁判をやったりして
人を殺したりしなくちゃいけないし
また地獄に落ちるんだと
ですから せいぜい六十年間ぐらいの王の王になってしまって
もう何百万年も地獄にはいたくないんだと
逃げたいんだと思っても
子供だから逃げられない
それでこの神が言ったのは
あなたは耳が聞こえないように
体が動かない人間のように
口が聞こえない人間のように
いわゆる身体障害者のようにいなさいと
そうすると 誰にも王にすることはできないんだと
で その人は十八年間一言葉も喋れないで
手も足も動かさないで
人が何言ってもまるっきり反応しないで頑張ったんだと十八年間
王様やらお医者さんやら体見て体見て
これおかしいんだと 全然病気じゃないんだと
こんな風には障害児は生まれませんと
いろんな工夫するんだけど
こちらは反応しない で
そこでまあ国民はこんな障害者は王様になったっても喋れない人だから
耳も遠いし 耳も聞こえないし
体も動けないし ですから意味がないんだと
でも他の人もこの人を処分しなきゃ王になれないんですね
一番目の息子だから ですから何とかしなさいと
言ったら 王様がまあ大変息子のことは愛情あったんだけど
しょうがない 法律だから
まあ処分するように命令するんですね
それで母親がもう泣いて泣いて
これはおかしいんだと
どう見てもこの子は障害者じゃないんだと
なんとかしてしたらこれ治るんだと泣いたんだけど
まあ父親はどうしようもないんだと言って
自分では殺せないし 自分で殺す命令もできないし
ですからこの国の領域から外に持って行きなさいと
持っていって そこで森の中で穴を掘って
ここで産みなさいと命令しちゃうんです
そこで言って まあ人々がこのまあ二人ぐらいね
国も離れていかなくちゃいけないんだから
車に行って で まあどうせもう動かない子だから穴を掘るんですね
そこで国の境界線の取ったところで
もう穴を掘り始めたんだから
その子はやっと生まれてから十八年経ったところで
もうちゃんと手も足もどうかな
動くかなと思って まあちゃんと動くんだと
もう立って待ってるんだそうです
ここに後ろに 誰も信じません
だからこの子動くわと
あんたこと一生懸命穴掘ってるんだけど
何のためかと これ王様に何かすごい不幸な子供が生まれて
王様に命令されて 今日ここに産むつもりですよと
ああそう どこにいるんですかね
車の中にいるんですよと
でもそこを見たら そこ誰もいないよと
あれと思って見たら誰もいないと
言ったら その若者は実はそれ私ですよと
言ったらみんな驚いて
どうしますか もう戻りましょうとね
なんでそんなことするんですかとかああだこうだと言ったら
あんた方何言うんですか
私は十八年間も家を出るために苦しみましたと
今更戻ると思いますかと言って
そのまま森に入って修行したんだそうです
まあストーリーを見ると
まあなんかほとんど嘘っぽい感じがするストーリーですけど
でもストーリーは嘘だと捨ててはいけないんです
どうせ嘘って読んだってもね
もうキツネは喋るわ ウサギさんが喋るわ
僕はあれでいいと思ってるんです
それ喋らなきゃ物語になりたたないんだから
ですから そのストーリーで言っているのは
この王様の息子で 王子で生まれたことは不幸だということなんでしょうね
皇太子様っていうんですかね
そういうクラウンプリンスで生まれるのはとんでもない苦しみ
とんでもない不幸だと
そのメッセージなんです
だからストーリーはどうでもいいんです
それは本当かないかって
ストーリーからおっしゃってくれるメッセージは正しいんです
考えてみてください もし遠い昔風な国で
王の息子で生まれたら
ただ不幸だけでしょうね
人殺して人殺して行かなくちゃいけない
隣の国の王はもう頭狂っちゃって戦争打ったら
こちらも行って戦争しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だからこの冗談じゃないんです
自分の国のこの今総理やってる女性なんですけど
まあ今歳ぐらいかな もう随分年で立って一人で立てないぐらいですけど
総理大臣ですけど 一応あまり仕事はしない
ただ飾りとしているんですけどね
娘が大統領になってるし
一応この前の選挙の時
彼女にみんな国民がね
この国はもうダメですよと
もう毎日人を殺して殺してる殺してると
前の政府はすごい汚いことやってきたんです
で 一般の一般人々ってものすごい殺しちゃったんです
だからもうあなたは選挙に出なきゃ
もう選挙では勝てないんだと
勝てなきゃ我々貧しい人々には立場がないんだと
みんな言ったんだけど
彼女言ったのは 今の国の状態は何ですかと
毎日これぐらい人殺すんだと
そこでテロたちが毎日人殺し戦争してるんだと
そこで私が選挙に出て大統領になって
軍隊を動かしてみんな殺せということですかと
そんな人殺しはやりませんと
すぐ断ったんです 彼女が出なかったらもう国が大変なんですけどね
ですから 私は一応選挙運動にはまあまあそれなりにできるだけ歳も歳ですし
まあ出ますけど 政治は駄目と
ものすごい頭良くて能力ある人なんですけど
やっぱり断ったんです
僕はあの話を聞いて まあこの人のこと結構昔からよく知ってるし
個人的にもよく知ってるし
だからやっぱり仏教の考え方活動してるなと分かったんですね
普通の人だったら国の大統領になってくれると言ったら
そこはもう大変喜んで OK するでしょうに
だからすごい力があるんで
彼女もし言ったら 私はもう歩けないんだから
あんた方行きなさいと
言っても国民が喜んで聞いてくれるんで
それぐらいすごい人気あるんです
でも 私は大統領になったら
私は今テロの問題やら全部解決しなくちゃいけないんだと
今まで殺された人々の問題も全部探して解決しなくちゃいけないんだと
結局私が人殺すことに命令しなくちゃいけないんだと
やりませんとそんなこと
で その代わりにやっぱりしょうがなくて
人々がじゃあ娘さんにお願いしますと
いて 今娘さんが大統領になってるんですけど
だからこの 僕は本当に驚いたのは
やっぱり欲ない 欲はないわけないんだけど
やっぱりこの人殺すことになるんだから
罪を犯すことになるんだから
まあ名誉を捨てると それは仏教で言ってるメッセージなんです
危ないと だから王様の息子で生まれるということは
もう一概には幸福とは言えないんです
他の人々 例えばある女性がもう世界一美人で生まれたんだと
みんな幸福だと思うでしょうね
どうなるんですかね そういう人々
人生無茶苦茶でしょうに
まああっち引かれて こっち引っ張られて
まあだこうだとか まあ結局普通の幸福な生活できなくなっちゃうんです
日本でもね あのなんかもう
ものすごい歌唱能力の人がいて亡くなったでしょう
何でしたっけ？あの人は
美空ひばりさん とか 私もあの彼女の歌唱能力っていうのは
まあなんか驚く 人間かと思うほどすごいんですね
やっぱり でも人生はどうですかね
だからもうどっちも言えないことなんですね
じゃあこのホームレスなんかの人々は不幸ですかと
これはもう何も言いにくいものなんです
もう家賃も払えませんし
でもちゃんとご飯食べてるんだと
ちょっと臭いだけなんですけど
だからこの生きるということは
そういう風に見て何も意味のないことなんです
それは人間のだけだけではなくて
動物の世界を見た時に
動物何やってるんですかと
必死で生きてて ただ自分の子供作るだけでしょ
子供作って子供大きくなったら自分が死ぬと
その子供は必死になって何やってるんですかというと
自分の子供を作ることだけなんですね
それ以上何もやらないんです
それで我々人間でおかしいということは
ああ素晴らしい 母親の愛情は素晴らしいとかね
命かけてまで自分の子供を守ってるんだとか
僕から見たらバカバカしい
素晴らしいではなくてバカバカらしいと
あなたは命かけてこの子供をね
人間ではなく動物でもね
命かけて育てたっても何になるんですかと
この連中も大きくなって同じことして死ぬだけですよと
だから何も意味がないんです
我々人間も子供が生まれたら
この子供のために何でもやりますよと思ったっても
結局それで人生全部終わっちゃうでしょうに
それ子供は何ができるんですかね
何のこともないんで 自分もまた同じ子供作って
こいつらのために命かけますよと
ただそれだけ ただそれだけのサイクルなんですね
そういうことで まあ言いたいのは
せいぜい私はずっと回講義で
いかに心をいい方向へ
ポジティブ方向へ持っていくかと色々教えたんだけどね
結局はそんなことをやったとしても何も意味ないんです
こんなくだらない人生のサイクル
やるためでしょ よく仕事できるんだと
よくちゃんと問題なく子供育てることできるんだ
だからなんですかと 昔もやってきた
やったんです 人間ってのはそんなことが
これからもやるんですね
だから仏教は本当はそこから始めたんです
その考え方から だから人間の考え方からはものすごいレベルが違うんです
この４回まで行ったのは
俗世間の一般の人々の見方から見て
仏教からちょっと引用しながら
その見方のところを解説しただけなんです
仏教のレベルから見たら
もう世の中こういう風に見るんです
無意味だと 虚しいんだと
だからすごい怖い話なんです
これはもうかなりもういろんなことを教えてからもう喋らなくちゃいけないことなんです
また まあ僕にしたっても
そこら辺からはもういくらでも百六十あって喋れますよ
何の遠慮なしにいくらでも言えるんです
僕はもう平気でいろんな他の宗教にでもね
まあまあ すごくもう失礼な言葉言ったりするのは
大体そういう立場なんです
もう何言ったっても結局は無意味でしょということで
別に個人的に誰に対しても何の恨みもないんです
恨む理由もないし わけもないし
あの人々を恨んでやろうと
何のためかと 全然 どうぞ勝手にやってくださいと
私のこともすごい恨む人々いるんです
ものすごい憎しみを持っても
なんとかしてやるとか
僕ははい どうぞお願いしますと
全然相手にしないんです
できるだけのことやってくださいと
日本のあの日本に来る前には
自分の国の何て言いますか
向こうの MINISTER OF EDUCATION
日本の文部省に当たるところで
そこで試験があって 我々も奨学金に選ばれたんですね
大体三百人ぐらいいたんだけど
四人選ばれたんです で
まあ四人にもそれなりの大変いろいろ経歴ですか
ありましたし まあですからもうちゃんとこのすごい偉い先生たちがもう試験で選んだんだから
もう誰にも文句言えないんです
で 私は面接に行ったところで
まあもうちょっと喋っただけで
みんな大変喜んじゃって
で まあこの人はもう OK だと決めて
まあ一応この最後にこのこの国のね
国と国間のあれだから
もう当時の総理大臣なんですね
係やってるの 彼がサインして最後の OK 出さなくちゃいけないんです
で まあ私はまあ大変有名なんで
総理批判するということで
で まあで それをそこに行くと
私と一緒に私はいろいろ助けてあげた友達たちがいて
まあその人々は必死になって私を名前をもうカットしようと
にしようと あっち行ってしゃべるは
こっち行ってしゃべるは
いろいろ政治家に行って話すわと
で そこである教授が私にもあんた知ってますかね
あなたの友達がこういうふうに今文部大臣にも話そうと行ってるんだと
一緒に二人一緒にいるんです
いつでも いて もう私に対してああいうことをやると言って
ああそう よく頑張ってくださいと言ってください先生と
とにかくしっかり頑張ってくださいと
と先生に言ったんですね
そこである日 僕にも聞こえたんです
その人の影響である人がもうなんとか関係あるんですよ
この文部大臣とその人も
で バス停で止まってバスが来るまである教授が待ってるんです
大学から帰るんで途中
で この人をあげて このスマナサーラさんなんかもう
もうなんか今度の奨学金に選ばれてるんだけど
まああれ 私はもう訴えたいと思ってるんですがと
で 僕は上からまた同じ大学で下りてくるんです
言って聞こえたんです
あの教授こう言うんですね
あんたはね 黙っていなさい
自分の骨を骨折れるだけですよと
あんた大統領のそういう
何でしたっけ フォーリガイン直接会って喋ったってもね
あれはOKになるんだと
黙っていた方がいいんじゃないかと
で 言ったら 僕はやっぱりまあ
まあそんなもので 誰にもそれもう何もできませんでしたし
ですから まあ戦わないんですね
まあ僕だったらどうぞやってください
その人々 くだらないね
嫉妬やら怒りやら そういうの戦う
もし私もそれに巻き込まれちゃったら
日本には来られないんです
巻き込まれなかったんだから
日本に来てひどい目合ったんです
勉強辞めたんだから ですから
このしゃべるときは厳しくいろんなことを言うんだけど
私はまああるまあ考え方があって
その立場から喋ってるだけなんです
ですから この世の中はね
まあこの恐ろしいことを我々はなんかこの銀紙みたいな
すごい薄い ちょっとしたことで破れるベールでかぶってるんですね
宗教はひとつでね 神様が我々にも魂を吹き込んだよとかね
聞くと本当に僕はイライラするんですね
偉そうに自分たちだけ人間だけ偉そうに威張っちゃって何言うんですかと
動物に神様が魂を吹き込んでないんですね
あれ 概念実体もくだらないでしょうに
もし神様が全部作ってみんなに魂を吹き込んだですよと言ったら
神様ってすごい大きい人だなと私は思いますけど
その人間だけに魂を吹き込んじゃって
人間に食うために動物を作ったんですね
だから嘘を言ったっても
いくらかこのアメリカ映画みたいでもね
なんとなく見て楽しい
聞いて楽しいぐらいでも嘘を言ってほしいんですね
それでもないんですから
で その時 小さい時 僕考えたのは
この豚なんか人間のために作ったんだけど
なんで豚泣くんですかと
殺す時は 皆様方はかわいそうです
もっと 豚屠殺するの見たことないでしょ？牛とか
見てください 一度も肉食わないんです
見たら また私のある友達がこのもう肉なきゃご飯食べないぐらいもう肉好きで
もうまあ仏教の国だからほとんど嫌うんですね
お母さんたちがね やっぱり子供たちが欲しいと言ったらもう嫌い嫌いということはできないし
もう作ってくれるんですね
そこでその人はまあ後でまあこの衛生政府の管理職なんですかね
そういう仕事に行ったんです
そこで訓練を受けて あの研究室
研究所に入って 訓練で衛生管理者になったんですね
ですから まあその地方を任せかけるんです
で 彼がこの何て言いますか
この研究じゃなくて その訓練を受けている時は
このいろんなところに行って勉強しなくちゃいけない
そこでこの牛なんか殺すところに連れて行ったんだと
連れて行って そのみんな牛を調べて
病気があるかないかとか
で 年は何歳かで全部調べて
その衛生士がOK出さないと売れないんですね
殺してはいけないんですね
だから殺す前に全部やるんです
で それから殺してからまたチェックするんです
だからこの人もまあノート買ってもって見て
いろいろ教えてくれるんだから
書いてみてながら あの殺す人に
あの自分の先生が審査出しなさいと言ったら
何のことなくサッと手を中に出す
取って はいはい先生と
行ったらこの人の牛だからこういうこういう感じだから
まあこれはまあ健康な牛ですよと
それそれっきりで肉食べない
だからあんまりにも残酷なんですね
だから知らぬが仏という我々見ないでしょう
日本の社会では 豚なんか殺す時はもう人間の子供のように泣くんです
もう骨の中までもう振動するんです
あの泣き声が あれで神様がもう魂吹き込んでないんだから大丈夫ですというふうに言うと
こちらが自分でサタンになりたくなるんです
だからこのまあ 誰にも批判する必要ないんです
みんな同じこの泥の沼で
この同じ罠に引っかかれているんです
このそういう神の概念やらああだこうだ言った人々も
同じ苦しみの中で ユダヤ人の人々にしたっても
もうすごい苦しみの歴史でしょうに
何のももう隠れて隠れて生活して
いろんな大変苦しみ それなのに選ばれた人間だというんですね
だから まあまあ 日本も一応戦争に負けていろいろ苦労しましたけど
タイとかね 戦前戦争に行ったこともなし
負けたこともないし 誰の植民地もなった形跡もないし
それだったら選ばれた人間というのはタイ国民だって言った方がもっといいかもしれません
なんでしょうかね あの言葉ってね
やっぱりそういうふうに自分の苦しみをごまかすんです
私たちは選ばれた人間だから
いつかあの約束の国が戻ってくるんだと
でも その歴史っていうのはあんまりにも残酷でしょうに
約束の土地は今あるんだけど
あれも法律違反ですからね
国際法律 アメリカの暴力で作った国だからね
私も本当にあの人々ってユダヤ人っていうのは本当にすっごい人々なんです
頭が良くて 今の世界全部支配しているでしょ
今の経済学 全部ユダヤ人の考え方だから
だからものすごい弱肉強食で互いに殺し合い
もう平和っていうのはまるっきりない世界でしょうね
まあそれはしょうがないんですけどね
仏教経済学でもあるならば
平和な経済学出てきますけど
まあみんな幸福になってほしいんだけど
これ不可能なんですね
相手を殺さなきゃ生きていられないシステムなんです
肉と魚食べなくたっても
米やら豆やら食べなくちゃいけないんです
豆一個見たっても ちょっと水にちょっとつけてみてると
次の日見ると本当にかわいいんですね
一生懸命この手足を伸び伸びてきて
まあじゃあそろそろまあという感じで出てくる
これ食べちゃいますからね
[背景音楽] そういうわけで
このすべては苦しみであるっていうことで
お釈迦様はね 空しいであると
意味がないんだと 手も足も出ないと
で お釈迦様はこの存在っていうのは燃えている
家に感じたんだそうです
家はもう東西南北どちらからにもものすごい燃えているんだと
その中で踊って何やってるんですかと
で 脱出しなくちゃいけないんだと
輪廻を脱出すると 存在を脱出すると
もう二度と存在しないと
存在するとまた同じことで
同じ繰り返しで だから仏教でこの輪廻の話あるんだけど
どうせ皆様方輪廻あるんだから安心しなさいというバカな話じゃないんです
そういうふうに言う人々いますけど
仏教ではそれは言わない
皆様方はこれっきりの人生ではない
もう将来もありますよと
未来がありますよと ですから
死ぬのは怖くないんですよとか
死ぬのは怖いんです 死んだらまた生まれるんだから
またやらなくちゃいけないんだよ同じこと
そこまでどこに生まれるかまだわからないんです
その時の感情によって
ですから 仏教というのは
ああいうこのすごいことを発見しました
輪廻あります 人間は生まれてもまた生まれ変わりますとかね
そういうストーリーではないんです
怖いストーリーなんです
輪廻を認める でも怖いと
この業の話で この なんで我々はこの不幸なこと
いわゆる悪ですか 不善をなぜやり
なぜ なんで不善を行いますかという説明したんですね
あの 我々の心の中で感情があるんですね
衝動が それは貪瞋痴なんですね
ほとんど我々その三つの感情で九十九パーセント一日の中で生きているんです
だけど それ全部不善なんです
例えば貪 て むさぼりっていうのは好きなことをやるということなので
母親は命かけて子供を育てたっても
自分の子供ほど好きなものはこの世の中で全然ないんです
好きで好きで好きでもう何でもやると
だから結局むさぼりでしょう
だから仏教から見れば
そんなに母親の愛ってのも美しいかどうかちょっと問題と
そこでその母親が同時にすごい怒りを持ってるんですね
もし誰か子供にちょっと叱ったならば
もし父親が子供にこれ何やってるんだと言ったら
もう母親がもう立ち上がるんだから
離婚までするんです 子供に叱るんだったら
もう私はうちに帰るんだと
それぐらい怒りもあるんです
愛情もあるんです 怒りもあるんです
そこでその男の子だったら
他のところからまた女の人を引っ張ってきたら
そこはまた あの子供に対する愛情で
また恨んじゃうんですね
だからこの我々はやっぱり罠にかかられてる
かけてかかられてるというか
もう引っかかってるんです
だから自分で子供産んじゃったら
自分の子供大事にする他の道がないし
子供は可愛いんだからまたしょうがないし
弱いんだから守ってあげなくちゃいけないし
せっかく自分が大きく育てたんだから
他のものに囚われるのは嫌でしょうし
だから自然法則によってそういう感情の流れが生まれるんです
が しょうがないということは仏教で認めない
だからしょうがないと
虎は鹿を食べてるんだから
まあしょうがないと いいよと
いいとは言えないんです
鹿にも生きる権利あるんだから
虎にも生きる権利はあるんだけど
鹿にもちゃんと生きる権利はあるんです
なんで虎のために鹿は死ななくちゃいけないんですかね
ですから すごいこの 六方からも火が燃えているんだと
慰めはないんだと それからこの貪瞋痴で我々行動しているんだから
ほとんど我々の行為 また不善行為なんですね
たまたま不貪不瞋不痴の行為をどうもしますよ
それは善行為なんですが
善行為 いいことをしてどうなるんですかねというと
王様の息子で生まれるんでしょう
あれでどうなるんですかね？あるいは世界一美人で生まれるとかね
男性の場合はすごい人気のある力士とかそんな感じで生まれたらどうなるんですか？まあ 18歳になると億万長者にはなるんだけど 30
歳で死んじゃうんですね
だからこのお釈迦様の道っていうのは全ての業カルマを捨てると
善も悪も捨てると それはまあ
お釈迦様おっしゃっおっしゃりたかった
本当におっしゃりたかったところなんです
ですから 天国に生まれても仏教ではあまり褒めないんですね
たまにあるんですね あの人は本当に低次元の天国に生まれたんだと
サーリプッタ尊者のお友達の人がね
本当にこのサーリプッタ尊者が死にかけている時はサーリプッタ尊者に会って
いろいろ話したところで
その人はバラモン人でしたからね
もう来世のことを教えたんですね
そこでもう梵天の話が出た途端
その人はヒンドゥー教の人だから
ああ 梵天というのは素晴らしいと
すぐそこに心が行ってしまっちゃったんです
そこで他のことを考えられなくなっちゃったんです
それでサーリプッタ尊者はしょうがない
このバラモン人だからね
仏教徒でもないし どうしても梵天に生まれた生まれ変わりたくなっちゃうし
だから梵天に生まれるようにしてあげようと思って
その人に梵天に生まれるように瞑想法をその場で教えて実践させちゃって
彼がしっかりそれを身についちゃって亡くなったんです
だからサーリプッタが説法をやって
尊者が説法をやって帰ると
その瞬間でその人は亡くなっちゃった
亡くなって約束通りに梵天に生まれ変わったんです
でお釈迦様は自分の舎利院のお寺で待ってる待ってる
待っていると サーリプッタ尊者がもう帰ってくるんですね
これとお坊さんたちにお釈迦様はこう言うんですね
あの人はね 自分の友達をね
今低次元のところに生まれ変わるようにして帰ってくるところだと
低次元の梵天に生まれ変わるようにして今帰っているんだと
もう批判したんですね
でもサーリプッタにも他の打つ手はなかったし
別に でもだから素晴らしいとはお釈迦様は言いたくなかったんです
そこだけポイントなんです
別にサーリプッタ尊者を批判してるわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様は自分の右腕だといつでも言ってるんだから
この人なきゃ仏教は成り立たない
それぐらい言ってるんです
ですから サーリプッタ尊者が精一杯やったことは知ってるんです
それ以上は あの死んだ人にとっては打つ手はなかったと
あなた素晴らしいんだと言っちゃったらどうなるんですかね
それから人間が やっぱりせいぜい死ぬ瞬間に梵天にでも生まれ変わった方がいいと思っちゃうんですね
それをやめるために あの人は低次元に送っちゃってね
自分の友達を ね 帰っているんだと批判したんです
だからお釈迦様はすごく鋭く
そういうところは気をつけて喋っているんです
だから たとえどこ どうに生まれたっても生命っていうのは他のところからエネルギーを取らなきゃ生きていられないんです
それ生命だけじゃないんです
物質も同じなんです なりたたないんですと
他のところからエネルギー入らないと
エネルギーは入る 入って出ていく
であの私たちはこうやって体が
もし私たちはこのまま誰か宇宙に
あの 何て言いますか ロケットでも宇宙に我々を打ち込んじゃったらどうなるんですか
もういきなり もし仮定してみましょう
このまんまで 何かこの道具もなしに
そのまま我々宇宙に行っちゃったら
そのままバラバラ爆発しちゃうでしょうね
体が ポーンと割れちゃうんです
粉々になっちゃうんです
なぜかというと 今はすっごい重い空気圧で
このアトモスフィアプレッシャーという
いわゆる気圧でちゃんと抑えられているんです
そこじゃなきゃ生きていられないんです
地球からずっと我々の体を引っ張ってるんです
朝も晩も夜も いつでも霧のぼっていたっても
地球はちゃんと引っ張って我々を捕まってるんです
そうでないと生きていられない
物質にしたっても もし我々は何も道具なしに海の中に入ってみたら
どうなるの？水の圧力でもう潰されるでしょうに
ですから 物事物質体もずっとエネルギーの流れなんです
存在と言ったってもそういうものであって
だから永遠なところはないんです
この前の話で このカルマの主体は何ですかという質問があって
僕はここですよと簡単に答えましたけど
主体はないんです 変化しない主体は
すべてのものはやっぱり変化しているんですね
噴水から見るとわかるでしょうね
ろうそくの炎あるでしょうね
ろうそくには炎があると
あるんだけど 何も主体がありますかね
主体はないんです ただ
ろうがとかといって 空気になって
乾燥と一緒になって 熱と一緒になって燃えて
炎という現象が作る それはずっと変化してあるんですね
流れが で 変化の流れ 我々は無視してろうそくの炎がありますよと言います
噴水を見て ああ綺麗 こちらは素晴らしい噴水がありますと思っちゃう
写真も撮る で 噴水があるんじゃないんです
そこに水はずっと流れている
その流れに我々は流れを無視して
変化していることは無視して
ああ噴水だと で 決めちゃう
川も同じなんです だからそういう例え
例え入りません 全てのものはそういう例えではないんです
そのものなんです 全てのものはそうやって変化していくんですね
そういうわけで どんな永久的な永遠な場所はないんですね
ありえないんです 科学的に考えると
なぜならば 永久的というのはまるっきり変化しないということなんです
で まるっきり変化しないところに我々はどうやって行くんですかね
行けないでしょうに そちら変化しないんだから
もし私がそこで生まれ変わったら
いくらかの変化が起こるでしょうに
だからうまれないんです
というよりは 永遠という次元はありえないんです
論理的に 変化だけでなければ存在はないんです
そういうのはまあなかなか難しい話なんですけど
で 今日言いたいのは この
不善をやってしまえば
ものすごい苦しみのところに生まれ変わっちゃうし
善を行ってしまえばいいところには行くんです
でもそこになったら落とし穴があると
いいところには行くんだけど
大変なんです 日本の社会を見ても
随分いいところに生まれる人々は大変でしょうね
あの人生っていうのは
例えば宝物いっぱいあるところあるでしょうね
それを守ることはどれほど大変かというと
いろんな古い高価なものをね
ちょっとしたもう紙に描いた絵なんですけど
今現代なんかテレビで見てたんだけど
なんとか何とか探偵団なんとかといって
この あの それ これはもう
軽く見ても五億円になりますよと
なんか有名な日本の絵なんですね
これは本物だと だからあのうちの人がね
あれ守らなくちゃいけない
あれしかなくて もういろんなものあったんですけどね
大変でしょうと思いますけどね
もし虫でも食っちゃったら
あれは国宝であるし ああ
大変だ だからお釈迦様はお坊さんたちに
この着る衣三枚と鉢だけで十分だと
物は盗すなと ということを言ってますけどね
髪の毛も剃ってみなさいと
伸ばすのは大変で 髪を伸ばしちゃったらどんなシャンプー使うかとかね
そのシャンプー体に合うか合わないかとかね
髪型は何にするかとかね
茶髪の色までね これ冗談じゃないんです
サンガ サンガを作るようなことはその執着
え？ サンガを作るようなことは
そこでまた名誉が生まれたり
財産が生まれたり 階級が生まれたり
そういうのが生まれる
サンガの中で  サンガを作ること自体
作ること自体 組織 ああまあそういういろいろ矛盾があります
でも随分お釈迦様は気をつけているんです
サンガは作りなさいとは言っていない
お釈迦様が作ったんだから作りなさいと言わないんです
自分で作ったんだから
え？ 後の人が勝手に作っただけ
いえいえ サンガはお釈迦様が作ったんです
グループは後のあとの人々は勝手に作ったかもしれませんだけど
まあサンガっていうのは全部お釈迦様が自分で決めて決めて決めて決めて作ったんです
ですから 初期的な時代のサンガの状況は
今も学者も言いますけど
まあこの弟に僕はインターネットでスリランカのお坊さんたちによく悪口言ってますからね
まあインターネットでみんなお坊さんたちに言ってる悪口は全部見ていたんです
でお坊さんたち英語を読まないんだから
英語を喋る連中は書いたい放題
私も書いてやろうかなと思ったんだけど
そんな時間無駄ですね
その時間で寝ちゃえばいい
で こういうことを言ってたんですね
サンガっていうのは お釈迦様が作って亡くなる時はリーダーを作らなかったんです
いわゆる うーん 何て言いますか
あれ 不思議なシステムなんです
誰もリーダーがないんです
一人一人独立しているんです
日本のもう日本で言ってるサンガっていうのは
我々が思ってるサンガっていうのは随分違うんです
我々  結局それを真似して
それが連破してブッダを連破してくるのは決してそういう風に変な解釈をやったり
何かそういうものを作っている
それはもう工程があるんだけど
お釈迦様は初期仏教の初期仏教そのままは時代的に出てこないんだから
少々変化はありますけど
リーダーがいないでしょうね
例えば初期仏教では 我々の場合はリーダーはいないんです
で 一応いるんだけど リーダーにも私たちにも権力は同じなんです
例えば我々の教えこそ正しい
我々の教えこそが真理である
ヴィパッサナーこそ真理
我々のヴィパッサナーこそ真理である
で 彼らは間違っている
クリシュナムルティは間違っている
これは集団じゃない 二階
浅森や二階にあるんじゃないですか
まあまあ そうおっしゃる通りに言うならばそうかもしれませんけど
そうは言ってないんですからね
そう理屈で言えばそう
だからね  どう言えばいいですかね
で そんなこの一般の人々いうレベルで全く喋れないし
で こういうこういう風な存在ですよと
だからその中でどうやって我々は抜け出ば抜け出せばいいかとというと
そこで何か方法見つかるんですね
だからお釈迦様いうのは
その方法は誰がいたって同じことですよと
これこそ絶対 これこそ唯一だと
それを仏教で禁じられているんだから
我々こそ唯一 我々の方法こそ
我々の方法こそ唯一の
そういう風には言わないんですね
それはもう仏教ではもう言ってはいけないことになって
うん それは全く言ってはいけないことで
お釈迦様も同じ理屈を他の人を批判するために使ってるんだから
例えばね まあ私こそ正しいやと私が言うと
他の人は自分こそ正しいって言う
あなたは間違ってるで言う
例えば人いると人の信者がいて
私だけ正しいんだと あなた方は間違ってるって言うと
それで他の人も同じこと言うでしょ
そうすると自分の教えに賛成券は 1票と否定券は 49 なんですね
だからどちらから見たっても同じことになっちゃうんですね
50人の間で ですから
そういう理屈はお釈迦様は全然使ってないし
で 最後にお釈迦様が亡くなる時は聞いた質問があったでしょうね
同じ質問なんです で この解脱
悟りとかね あなたはずっとおっしゃってきたんだけど
あなた方の弟子たちは悟っているんだとかね
仏教だけですかと 悟るのは
そこはいえ 違いますよと
それはまあこの通りに全ては苦しみであるドッカであることを見て
それは渇愛によって生まれるんだと
それを発見して その中道実装実行すると
人は誰であろうが申し訳なく悟りますよと
そこですよと  仏教と全く無関係で
仏教なんか知らなくて
あるいは浄土真宗から言えば
浄土とも言われるシベトニ教とかね
そういう中にいる世界にいて
で 言いたいことはこれでしょう
もうそういう話はこの仏教ではこのよく認めてるんですね
この仏教でよくパッチェーカブッダという言葉があるんです
で パッチェーカブッダっていうのは
このパッチェーカっていうのは各々という意味で
その人 その人という まあインディビジュアルという意味なんですね
まあ日本語で何言ってるか
あんまり日本的に まあいわゆる独立している人々なんですね
独立ブッダたちって意味なんです
だから悟りの道は 3つありまして
悟る方法ですか  昇学者になるか
パッチェーカブッダになるか
お釈迦様の教えを聞いて簡単に悟るかという 3つなんですね
このパッチェーカブッダという独立した人々っていうのは
時空 時間 時代に関係なく
あっちこっちで悟りを開くと
そういう人はいるんです
で いるんだけど そんなもう簡単に考えられることではないんです
だから一応基本的には仏教ではそんなことは何のことなく認めていることで
お釈迦様も自分の教えに対して古い道と
プラーナ・アンジャサンというお経があります
サンユッタ・ニカーヤ
このプラーナ・アンジャサンというお経の名前も
これプラーナっていうのはオールド
アンジャサンっていうのはパス
古い道と 仏教っていうのは古い道だよと
どういう意味かというと
お釈迦様はもうすごいことを自分だけで何かもう発見した
発明したんではなくて
真理を探していったら
その通りに見つかりましたと
世の中にあること ですから
私はこの通りに修行して悟りましたと
でも私以前 数えられない人々も全く同じ方向で悟りましたと
一応私は今の現代文明の人々にその道を言葉にして
いろいろお尻をお印をつけて
四聖諦八正道という言葉を持って喋ってるだけですよ
いわゆる古い町をお釈迦様発見して
その町に行く道順を教えてるだけですから
あの 今聞いてるような質問には
仏教はあんまり関係ないんです
でもちょっとしたこのそこに落ちがあるんです
で 誰が悟っても道は同じですと
例えば この全ては無常であるということは否定しては悟らないんです
やっぱり永遠だと思っちゃえば悟らないんです
永遠だと思っちゃったらそこで引っかかっちゃうんですね
捉えられるんですね また
論理的に永遠ということはもう不可能なんですね
人間には実体のある魂があるんだと思っちゃったら悟らないんです
そこで思っていても 自分を発見し
自分を発見していくと
このすべての現象は流れてあるものであって
一時的な現象であるということがわかって
やっぱり無意味だとわかったところで悟るんですね
ですから もうクリシュナムーティ悟ったっても
今の誰か誰が悟ったっても
道は同じなんです ヴィパッサナーっていうのは見なさいという見る方法だけであって
別になんのこともないんです
それは例えばこのラージャヨガ
ハタヨガとか ヨガのいろいろ方法があるでしょう
それとはまるっきり違うので
ヴィパッサナーで見なさいと見る方法 Observation
ですから  お釈迦様はですね
生老病死は苦であると説かれましたよね
今お話聞いてますと 生は苦である
生は苦しくて苦しいのだ
というだけでなんか十分ような気がするんですけど
それをあえて老病死までくっつけて
生に老病死までくっつけて
生老病死は苦であるというような書き方に
生は苦であると言えば十分だと
それはまあ  なんでそういう余計なものを
なるほど 余計なじゃないんです
だから生は苦であると理解するためには大変な説明をしなくちゃいけないんですね
私ももうなんかもうたまる
なんて言いますか 日本語であれば
なんかもういいって だけど言えなくて
言えなくて 言えなくて
言えなくて やっと今日も本当は言いたくはないんです
今日も ちょっと早すぎだと思ってるんです
今日も ですから ただ 生は苦であると言ったっても
人間には理解できませんね
ですから お釈迦様こう言うんです
私は同じことをありとあらゆる言葉で
ありとあらゆる表現で
いろんな例えで言いますよと
人々はそれは自分の理解できる角度で理解しなさい
が この教えの差によって喧嘩するなと
言葉の表現のディファレンスオブエクスプレッション
だからエクスプレッションの表現の差を見て喧嘩する意味がないんだと
ですから 私たちには生は苦であると言ったら理解できるかもしれませんだけど
この中でもそれで理解できない人々はいるんです
このグループの中で で
ですから もう他の言葉を言わなくちゃいけないんですね
もう一つ この輪廻ということなんですけどね
輪廻するといさされてもですね
それを信じられる人と信じられない人がいると思うんですよ
それは仏教は科学的なものだと何回も言ってますよね
それを誰にも信じられるように
いわば科学の言葉でですね
説明するということはどういう風にするんですか
それは私たちは科学で勉強しなくちゃいけないと思いますけど
科学の今の概念は足らないんですね
私もいろいろ考えてみたんだけど
やっぱりまだ科学を発展してもらわなきゃ困るんです
これぐらいではもう科学にならないんです
科学というものは本当の科学に到達していないから
まだ発展途上でしょう
科学っていうのは まあそれみたいな
この波動の物質は波動の具合にあるよというのも
まあもう最近出たばっかりでしょうに
このクォンタムフィジックスだとかどうとかね
僕はそんなことさっぱりわかりませんだけど
だから仏教はもう最初から当たり前のようにそういうことを言ってるんだから
で 我々の今もする解釈っていうのは完璧じゃないんです
今の人間にわかるような解釈をしているだけで
ですから 僕もすごく厳しくいろいろ注意されたんで
先生たちにね あんまりあなたこのいい加減な科学なんか過度を使うなと
それ大変無垢なことになるんだと
仏教は死んでしまっちゃうんだと
科学は今日明日で終わりますよと
だからまあ まあそれはまあ
その先生方はもう大変なもう経験者たちだから
やっぱりよく知って喋ってるしね
だからまあ科学はもっともっと次元を変えて変えて
いろいろなことをやっちゃうと
言葉もそちらで作らなくちゃいけないんですもん
僕は仏教には言葉はいりません
我々はもう今持っている言葉で十分です
無常とか無我とか空とかね
因縁とか そういう言葉で十分です
そこであの 一つ言いたいのは
この輪廻はもう信じる人もいて
信じない人もいるし 僕らから見ればどっちでも同じなんですね
ただ 輪廻は信じて信じてるだけで
知ってるわけじゃないし
ある人は輪廻を信じてないだけで知ってるわけじゃないしね
ですから あなたは信じてるんだから輪廻あるとも言えませんし
私は信じませんだから輪廻ないとも言えませんしね
ですから そういうことは
人は個人的に信じるか信じないかということはそんなに問題ではないし
信じさせる必要もないし
まあそこら辺はあんまり
まあほどほどに気にしない方がいいと
ベストに そこでそれの代わりに言いたいのはこういうことなんです
もし輪廻だったら 我々はこうやっているでしょう
例えば過去から 過去から未来まで行くでしょう
だからこれも無限で もうこれも無限なんですね
とにかくまあ とにかくそれはpastといえば
僕はちょっと日本語書きにくいだから
これはまあfutureとすれば
我々は過去からもうずっと流れるんですね
もう川の川ですから そこでこれを輪廻というでしょうし
だから現在ということがあるでしょう
なということが 今例えば我々ヒューマンという思えばね
今人間にいるんだと だから同じ流れでしょ
で 人間にて死んで これで天に生まれても
そこで死んじゃって地獄に落ちても
輪廻という時間の軸でしょう
ですから自分のことを勉強すれば
過去があるかないかではなくて
このリンクだけ勉強すればそこで輪郭わかるんです
だからお釈迦様はまあ今自分のことを見なさいと
世界の多くの宗教というか
ユダヤ系の宗教ですけど
始まりと終わりがあるんだと思って
大部分の人々がそれを信じて疑わない
まあ文脈的にどっちか分からないし
五割の確率があると思うんですよね
全然わからない 意味があるかどうか
五割に分かれる で これこれこれ
これでしかありえないって言われると言われると
そうでない考え方もあるなと思うんです
そうでない考え方 どういうふうに出れる？ だから始まりなんてものは
だからそういうふうに話にならないね
例えば始まりがあるということが
本当に信じてる人が私の前に出てこないと
私に何も答えられないんです
しかし どちらともわからないって言ってる
いや これはわかります
科学の物質の世界でも
もうエネルギーの何フラムでしたっけ
ストロンとかなんとか言ってるでしょう
物質っていうのは仮の姿
物質は仮で仮ですけど
変えて変えていくでしょうね
全部仮の姿なんですけど
でも本物の姿がないんです
いわゆる一つの現象がかえって違う現象に変わる
僕はどっちでも別に変わらないんで全然変わらないんだけど
ただキリスト教の人のお話を聞いた
それのお話を聞いていると
やっぱり自分のこの世界観と混じりになってくるんですね
それそれは今 これは仏教の世界観
それと仏教の人の話を聞くと
僕はそういう宗教の人の話も聞くのが好きなんで
いろいろ聞くんだけど
えっと これも我々の考え方
我々というか お釈迦様が我々はお釈迦様のおっしゃるとおりだから
お釈迦様が  どう受け取るかっていうのは個人の自由です
別にどうったことないんです
でも私 私の仕事っていうのは
これはこういう考え方だよと
こういうふうに考えてるんだけど
はっきりと言うことなんです
私は決してキリスト教に遠慮する必要はないんです
キリスト教に遠慮してそちらいろいろ言わないです
キリスト教の人々は仏教に遠慮する必要ないんです
けど 一つすごい根本的なことなんですけど
あれはカルマですね 釈迦の道はすべてのカルマを捨てることですけど
で その修行者 釈迦の弟子と称する人々
いろんなところにいろんな形で見かけるんですけど
釈迦の弟子と称する人々がその説教する法務審議会の教祖つまり釈迦の弟子
弟子から仏教 仏教を転生していましたね
仏陀 仏教とらって言ってました
そして説教する そういうふうに説教する
動機っていうのは が知りたいんです
もしそういう そして怒ったりムキになったりなんか
そういうことが悪いことの積み上げでやめればいい
なんで  その人に聞いてください
先生は  私は怒りませんだからね
なんかムキになって 態度
そういう態度なきゃ喋れないだけで
僕はあなたがあなた方ほど日本語も知りませんし
必死になって外国語で喋ってるし
で ほんの僅か言葉知りませんし
じゃあなぜその説教するっていうことに何か得るものがあるんですか？ 全然
怒りだけ人の 違うだけ
お坊さんが説教するっていうことに
世界中で説教するわけですね
したりなんかしてるわけですね
まあ我々は命透けてるんだから
まあ死ぬまでは何とかしてるんです
例えばここに来ているような人は
大した先生から見れば大したことなくてね
泥沼の天国の地獄みたいな泥の中を這いずり
泥の中を這いずり回っているような人間だと見えるでしょうが
そういう人間に多分理解してもらえないようなですね
説教するというのはよっぽど強い使命感がないとね
よくもあなた話聞いてるんですね
それでもね だから仏教というのは論理がすごいきついんです
ですから 日本人とはね
すごくこのちょっと論争できないんです
インド文化っていうのは論争でも文化的にできてるんだから
僕に答えられますけど
ちょっときつい  そういう言い方だとごまかし
ごまかしじゃない だからいくら泥沼の話は持っていっても
わしは怒ってない 怒ったのは喋るんだけどね
その泥沼にいる人はわからないでしょうと思っているんだけど
あなたも同じ一人でしょうし
泥沼にいるし それでも話聞いてるでしょうに
ですから 私の仕事には意味があるんです
どういう意味があるんですか
聞いてもでしょう  そうすると何か意味がある
私いなくたって聞いてる人にあるんです
先生いなかったら意味がない
先生の利益がないんですよ
それは自分の考え方でしょうね
だから正しい行為っていうのは別にね
まあ利益がなくやることなんです
僕みたいな泥沼にいる人間にはね
利益が 私は利益がなく
正しいから みんなの幸せのために正しいからいいって
私には利益がないが みんなの幸せのために正しいことをやりますっていう人間っていうのは信用しない方がいいんじゃないかっていう
私は それ自分で考えて私に当たろうとしてるんですね
そういう だからそういう世界にいるから仕方ないんですよ
だから僕 僕にとってはそれは全然関係ないんです
僕はもうただまあ聞いてる人がいるんだから喋ってる
だから私は一応確認してるんですよ
だから聞いてる人がいるんだから喋っている
実践する人がいるんだから
修行方法を教えている
それで成り立ってるだけのことで
誰も話聞かないと僕も喋れないし
ねえねえ聞いてよって絶対言わないんだから
ねえねえ 私の話聞いてよとかね
やっぱり僕は別に専門家じゃないですけど
何もわかりませんが スッタニパータですね
素直に見ますと 素直に読み込むと
やはり罪悪一人で死ぬしなさいって言ってますね
で もし人と一緒に修行する場合でも
自分より卑しいか優れたもの
自分より優れているか
あるいは自分より卑しいものを伴って一緒に修行しなさいとありますね
ここにいる人はみんな先生よりこの下を這い回るような劣った人間ばかりじゃないかと思いますけど
一応それ来てるわけだから
そういう子たちと交流しちゃっていい
煩悩の中で一番悪い恐ろしい煩悩っていうのは慢なんですね
だから あの日本のお坊さんとぐらい比丘とは違うんだが
僕は日本のお坊さんですけど
我々の利益のためにしますけど
比丘というのは例えばサマッダラね
今死んでもいいんですよ
だから生きてるからね
ただ生きてるから スッタニパータを見ると
いいですか ちょっといいですか
どうぞどうぞ  スッタニパータを見ると
比丘はって書いてあります
修行者は一人で犀の角のように行ったらいいといわれています
修行終わった後どうすんの？そのまま住んだらさっきのバッチャとかだよね
修行終わった人はそのままその人に
武器にならなくていいんです
武器になったら  先生はじゃあ修行完成しちゃった
そのままここにいても修行できるし
山にいても修行できるんですよ
だから修行者はね 別にここで別に修行終わったとか終わってないとか
結局何食わして聞きたいんですか
聞きたくもないんですけど
あの質問がちょっと絞ってくれる
いえ まあ質問が絞ってくれないんですね
私にこれに答えなさいと
簡単に やっぱり先生 先生が
先生がここで修行なさる
そのことは お釈迦様の教えに反しない
そういうふうに簡単に簡単ではなくて
私の質問を絞ってくれないと
そのことを先生がここでお話を説教されることがとか
あまり失礼だと思うので
ちゃんと質問させてください
そういう動機に異議とか言ってもないのか
釈迦の教えに反しないのかっていうことを聞きたいんだけど
それを言っても意味がわからないです
わかります  いいのか 普通
じゃああまりにも抽象的に
いいですよ それはすごい具体的ですけどね
何かっていうと 釈迦はなるべく一人で修行しなさいって言ってる
で 自分より優れた人だけなさい
先生は釈迦の弟子なの？ うん
だから私は答えます 質問は
私はここで喋ることはお釈迦様の教えに反しているのではないかとね
アゲインストブッダステーチングということですよ
英語で言えば で お釈迦様は悟ってから 60人の弟子を作って何を言ったんですかというと
チャルタ・ビッパ・チャーリカン
この道教えが世の中にないんだと
誰にもこれなかなか発見できないんだと
これ思考パターンも違いますから
ですから これは教えてあげなくちゃいけないんだと
特許を作って自分だけのものにしてはいけないんだと
ですから 比丘 比丘尼になったということは
もう人々に喋ることは修行の一部なんです
ですから お釈迦様もマエーケーナデーアガミッタ
あの時は 60人しかいないんだから
一人一人で歩きなさいよということもあるし
学者はまたいえ二人で歩けと言ったんではないか
またもう一人一人一人で歩けていったんではないかという
ちょっとあの翻訳のまだまだ決まってないところがありますけど
まあ一般的に考えれば 60人だから
インドは広いんだから
まあ一人で歩けと 世の中で歴史的に現れたファーストミッショナリーリリジオンというのは仏教なんです
他の宗教はミッショナリーやってなかったんです
ミッショナリー 伝道 歴史的に見ると
お釈迦様は悟ってもう 1年ちょっと 1
年でもう弟子をみんなにこの解脱の道を教えてあげなさいと
わかる人はいるんだと
わかる人はいたんだから
もうそれだけなの  面倒見いいと
別に私は面白くない それで先生から私が話を聞くのが嫌だ
面白くなかったって むしろ私はいいんだけどっていう話
私は面白かったけど  別に僕も弟子じゃないんだけど
私はだってこの質問を絞ってこてもらわないと答えられないんですね
もしお互いにすごい時間があるんだったら
僕はもういくら何でも喋れますけどね
でもあの ちょっとね 僕も外人だから外国語で喋ってますよ
ですから結構厳しいんです
僕の頭の中でも あの質問絞って欲しかっただけ
はい  いい あの なんか何でもいい
お釈迦様はね 僕が読んだ限りだと
最初はその悟りを得た後に
その人に教える教えないで
そのまま涅槃に入ってしまうと思ったんだけれども
そのなんか動転か何かインド亜種かなんかやって
その説得されて思い直したっていうことですね
うん やっぱりお釈迦様自身もそういう人に教えるってことについて考え方が最初と始めて始めて悪いというか
変わったんじゃないかって
まあ教え方もいろいろ変えたしね
一番  教えるか教えないか
それはまあ お釈迦様が説法している途中でも
まあ人が話を聞かないと
もう出て行ったところありますからね
弟子たちが話を聞かない
わがままよ じゃあ勝手にしろとお釈迦様はもう山に入ったんです
ですから聞いてると教える
修行すると指導する 聞いてないと黙っていると
亡くなる時までも同じことでしたから
亡くなってこの最後に横になった時でも
もうすごい病気で もう赤痢で
もう何にもできない状態で
その時でも一人が来て
とにかく亡くなる前に話を聞きたいと言ったら
まあどうしてくださいと
説教するの修行ですって言ったのは
えっ  説教するの修行ですか
まあそうでも言ってないんだけど
説教する人にとっては厳しい
いろいろ条件つけたりもありますけどね
ものすごくきちんと全部セットシステムできてるんです
で 我々も説教するって言ったってもね
もっと基本的なことを心の中に入れてるんです
それがあって それ尺度があって
ガイドラインがあって
その中で喋ってるんです
そういうのは普通にはなかなかもう教えること難しいんです
弟子入りするならば教えてあげますけど
そうでないとはね 難しいしね
で 椅子でのまあそれすごいいろいろシステムあります
とにかくこのお釈迦様も伝道活動しました
それからこの前いろんなことを言ったんですね
ああだこうだとか比べたり比べたりとか
その比べる概念自体 仏教は否定するんです
そこも最終的に悟らない限り
このマナという煩悩は消えないんですね
マナっていうのは この英語で言えばコンペアリングなんですね
コンペアは比較する 測る
測るんですね 自分と他人を
それで最初から自分がいるという概念あって
それで他人と測っちゃうんですね
私は偉いと あんた方は偉くないと
ああだこうだとか その比較することさえ仏教はもう否定するし
それはもう解脱得たら全部消えちゃうんですね
だから解脱を得ても得なくても
仏教たるものは 特に出家は全く比較してはいけないんです
お釈迦様が 29歳ぐらいで出家されましたよね
そのそれまでの人生の中で
人生は楽しいとか 人生は嬉しい喜びであると思われたことは一度もなかったんですか
あまりわかりませんね
言ってないんだから記録ないですからね
すごい贅沢をしたんだと私は最期ではと言うんです
でもお釈迦様は自分の口で言ってるのは全部つまらなくて捨ててきましたと
無意味でした 自分のヤソーダラー夫人ですか
この奥さんのことはよく褒めたんですね
亡くなった時はね あの人は最期の時はもう素晴らしい人でした
ということもあるんです
ですから まあ一般の人間でいたんだから
それなりに楽しかっただろうと思いますけど
何もこの僕にはっきりと答えるぐらいの信頼できる記録はないんですね
少しでもそういう楽しいと思う瞬間
クリアというのはちょっと普通に言ってしまうのは
なんかちょっとおかしいかなって思いますけどね
そこら辺はね 難しいでしょうし
まあ普通の普通の人間として見た方がいいんで
お釈迦さんはね 普通の人間で
子供で生まれて大きくなって
それで鋭い感覚あったんだから
もう全部このヴェールを破ったと
性のヴェールっていうのは
やっぱり出家する時でもうすでに破っちゃったんですね
でも悟りはもう後のこと
ですから あの前の質問にもっと戻って喋りますけど
あの あの 例えば私が知ってるんだ
あなた方は知らないんだとかね
そういうふうに自分と他を比べること自体も
仏教においてはもう悪いカルマなんですね
カルマでいえばすごい煩悩なんですね
そこで心は完璧になったら
もうその概念さえ消えちゃうんです
だからこの説法する人々も
私は昨日もこの喫茶店で言ってましたから
教える時でも自分のことを捨てて教えてくださいと
自分を守ろうと思って喋ると
自分を褒めて褒めてもらおうとと思って
学校で先生を教えると上手くいかないんだと
ですから 立派な先生になりたければ
自分の命を捨てちゃって喋った方がいいんだと
だから我々は説法するもそういう立場なんです
人に批判されようが 貶されようが
そんなことはあまり気にしないで
自分を守るためではないんです
だから自分を守ることになったら
なかなか喋りにくいんですね
相手側からすごく褒めてもらわなくちゃ自分を守られませんからね
だからこのある程度でこの自分を捨てるんです
で その時は結構避けられるし
教えられるしね そういうことで
この煩悩の一つなんですね
マーナっていうのは 比較すること
じゃあ一応話に戻りますが
我々はどうするべきかというと
まあ順番で考えちゃうと
まずもう汚れた行動はしないのはしてはいけないっていうことは当たり前のことなんです
汚れた行動は絶対もうできるだけしてはいけません
で 絶対しないようにと決めた方がいいんだけど
それはもうできるわけじゃないんですけどね
人間心が汚れているんだから
それから汚れている行動の代わりに 2
番目に我々汚れる行動をやめる代わりに
我々は良い行動でそれを入れ替えるんですね
いわゆる善行為をする
汚れた行動をやめと行動をやめろ
辞めてからそれからもう善行為を行うと
で そこでいくらかはまあいいんじゃないかなと
で それからの問題なんですね
いい行為をすると いいところに生まれ変わったり
人間の人生の中でも もう来世なくてもいいことをする人はよくなるんですけど
でもその中でまた落とし穴あるんですね
立派に仕事をする人はちゃんと成長はするんだけど
その分どんどんどんどん苦しみが大きくなるということもあるんです
仕事をごまかしたりする人は不幸になってしまいいっちゃいます
それまた不幸になってしまうし
ですから 結局どっちにしたっても
まぁあまり意味がない
意味がないんだけど もう道は決まってる
仕事に例えて言うならば
仕事をごまかすよりは正直に仕事をした方がいい
じゃあ正直に仕事をするとどうなるかというと
自分がどんどんどんどん成長しちゃう
それでどんどん仕事が大きくなっちゃう
複雑になっちゃう 責任が多くなっちゃう
どんどん家に帰られなくなっちゃうし
会社の責任 全部自分一人の肩になる可能性もあるし
それは真面目に仕事をしただからなんですね
で 立派な人になったのはなったことはなったんだけど
なってどうなったんですかという質問もどこかで出てくる
そこで仕事をごまかした人だったら
まあいろいろみんなに差別されたりとか
いじめられたりとか 会社でいられなくなったりとか
やがてもう法律的に何か捕まるとか
なんか不幸になってしまうし
ですから そういう不幸になるよりは
あまりにも忙しくてね
成長している状態は一番いいんですね
いくら忙しくたっても
子供の顔を見る暇もなくたっても
まあその方行くしか道がない
それでお釈迦様はまた 3段目の道を教えるんですね
3段目の道は業を脱する道なんですね
だから会社に例えてみてください
会社で仕事をごまかしたり
会社のお金をいろいろ横領したりする生活はいいかといえば
それは当たり前 良くないと
真面目に仕事をすればいいということ
それに我々こちらでは
仏教でいうのは悪い 不善行為をするよりは善行為をした方がよろしいと
そうすると良くなりますよと
幸福になりますよと それでまた会社に戻って考えちゃったら
会社の社長なんかになっちゃったら
もう大変なんですね まあそれなりに
普通のサラリーマンとは違う
いろんな忙しくなる いろいろ政治家と関係を持たなくちゃいけない
あっちこっち外国走り回らなくちゃいけないとかね
会社によっていろいろ大きくなって
仕事大変になっちゃうんですね
だからせっかくいい立場に乗ったのに
登ったのに あなたにちょっと休む暇もないでしょうと聞きたくはなるんですね
第三者からは 休む暇もないし
寝る暇もないし それで体早く壊すでしょうしと
事実はそうなってしまうんです
そういう人々は体を早く壊しちゃって
もうすぐ死んでしまっちゃうし
それであれ 会社の仕事をしないで
お金盗んだ人とかと同じ結果になってしまうし
ですから そこをまとめてもっと高いレベルで見ると
まあ 0点だろうと いわゆるあまり点数が入れなくなっちゃうんですね
引いて足して引いてみたら
もう全部五分五分になって 0点になるんだと
それで第 3番目の道っていうのは
輪廻を脱出する道 いわゆる業を乗り越える道なんですね
業を乗り越えるということはどういうことですかと
で この前 説法を作る前にいろいろお話なさったんですね
そのそちらに答えがあるんです
いいことをするんだけど
それをもって自分に何か利益があるんですかとね
考えないんです それは皆様にもう覚えてるでしょ
あなたは今説法しているんだと
あなたに何も利益がなければ
何のためにやってるんですかという質問ですから
もう利益のためにやるんだったら
あの会社の真面目に仕事をすることと同じで
何の利益もないんだけど
いいことをするんだと
それは業を脱出する道なんです
あなたは私を褒めてくれなくても
私はあなたに教えてあげると
で 一般の普通の業の世界では
私たちは人を助けてあげる
助けてあげてから それを結果として自分も幸福になると
それは利益を求めているんですね
会社で真面目に仕事をする
その結果としては 自分がどんどん成長していくと
給料もそれなりに伸びていくと
それは利益があるんです
そこで三番目の道っていうのは会社に真面目に仕事をする
あんた課長になったらどうですか？で
いいえ ごめんなさいと断ります
これでいいと 利益を否定する
そうしたら何のために仕事するんだ
ただ仕事するだけです
その道は三番目の道なんですね
それは あの 再起の世界では成り立たないんです
何かやっぱりね やりとりの世界だから
何か見込みがないと利益がないと行動はできないんですね
で わかりやすい例を言います
で あの仏教ではよくお布施の話があるんで
お布施することはいわゆるいいことだと
人っていうのは正直にお布施はしたくないんですね
お布施っていうのは何か人にあげることなんです
あげたくはないんだ 自分のものだから
なんであげるんですかと思うのは正直なところで
そこであげたくないんだから
あなたはね 自分一人だけ食べると不幸になるんだよ
物はなくなりますよと
ですから あげる人はもっと豊かになりますよと思ったら
その人に欲があるんです
あ そうかそうか あげたら豊かになるんですか
じゃあそれだったらあげますと
で 自分持ってるものをお布施すると
で その人がお布施するのは
ちょっとしたなんか商売みたいな感じなんですね
人にものをものを与えたらたくさんもらうんだと
それは普通の前の質問に出たきた次元なんですね
何か得があって 利益があって行動しているということで
で 次の次元は あなたの心が汚れていると
ものに囚われているんだと
あなたは心の汚れをなくさなくちゃいけないんだ
心は汚れている限りは
あなたは不幸ですよ それで心の汚れをなくすために
一つの訓練として持っているものを捨てなさいと
人にあげなさいと 礼もいらんと
あなたに とにかく自分持っているものから身を軽くしなさいと
ということで 私にはこんな金の時計があるんだから
これ守らなく これめんどくさい
じゃああげますと なんであげるんだよ
いや あれはめんどくさいんですよ
だからもうあげてせいせいしましたと
それもお布施なんですけど
前のお布施とは違うんです
しっかりしました 全部あげちゃって
仏教で出てくるお布施の話はだいたいそういう話
菩薩はこのいろいろお布施した話があるんで
そのストーリーを今日言いたかったんだけど
あの ある時 お釈迦様の先生のまたストーリーで
まああの 生まれて ある家で生まれたんですね
で 両親が亡くなったんですね
すごい金持ちの家で生まれたんです
で 両親が亡くなったら
この会計士の人々がみんな集めて会議をやって
で この家のこの大体三財産をこの人にこれから全部教えてあげなくちゃいけないんだと思って
この人に訓練してあげるんですね
連れてきて いろいろ この財産はあなたのお父さんが残していた財産だと言って
ものすごい財産見せるんですね
これぐらい これぐらい
これぐらいあるんだよと言って
記録 記録をいろんな見せると
それで これで疲れて疲れてもう何日間もかかるんだから
そっちにそれで終わって
いえ まだ終わってないんだと
おじいちゃんの財産まだあるんだと
そこでまあやれやれと
それでおじいさんの財産のことを全部もう勉強して終わって
で またひいおじいさんのこともあって
それ七代目まで で これでこの菩薩はあれ？と気が付いちゃったんです
七代目までこれくらい財産残って
六代目これぐらい財産残って
日本だったら残りませんね
相続税取られますけど
昔でよかったんですって
で  五代目これでよく 四代目
それ自分の父親もあれ苦労してこんなにお金残して
この五千僧は一人もこれ持っていってないんだと
あ 私は全部持っていくんだとすぐ決めちゃった
私は持っていく で 何をしたんですか？というと
もうあの会計士の人々はうるさくて
いろいろ教えたり それを計算させたりするでしょうね
はい 分かった分かった
全部終わったでしょう
もうやっと終わったと
で 次の日は全部報告出したんです
国の人々はみんな出てこいと
出てきて 自分好きなものは好きな放題持って行きなさいと
何も遠慮する必要はない
言って もう全部土地から家から
この家が欲しい人は持って行き
持って行きなさいと 言って
全部もらって みんなにもらって
あ 一応に一枚ぐらい腰巻ぐらい私にちょうだいと
自分が腰を巻く一枚ぐらい持って山に上がったんです
ですから そのそれは何の徳のためにやったんですかと言うのは馬鹿馬鹿しいです
この仏教で この仏教のこの意味
価値観ですか 価値観 価値観言うためにそのストーリーがあるんだから
あの菩薩大したものではないかと
たったもう硬い布 一枚だけもらって
また自分のものでしょうにと森に入って
何が馬鹿馬鹿しいと思うかもしれませんけれど
そうじゃないんです 何のために全部清算してあげたんですかと
国の王にでもなりたかったんで
それ何もないんです ただ山に入りたいだけ
山に入りたい これ財産は邪魔です
心に残るんです 管理しなくちゃいけないんです
給料払わなくちゃいけないんです
人を仕事してると病気になったら
それ面倒見なくちゃいけないんです
だから心の束縛だと で
布施をする その布施はお釈迦様おっしゃっているこの第三番目の道
心を清らかにするためにやると
得を得るためにやるのではなくて
心を清らかにするためにやるんだ
ですから 私にとっても説法することは一つの徳があるんです
私はしっかりしなくては説法できないんです
だから私はしっかりしているんです
誰にも負けない で 知ってることもしっかり知ってるんです
で 私は中途半端で そうではないか
ではないかとか 状態ではもう喋れませんし
僕はものすごいガキの頃から説法してましたからね
まあ二千二年 三年でも説法始めたんです
それはそれで ですから
その時からやっぱり知るものはしっかりしなくちゃと
やることはしっかりやらなくちゃ
で かえって人間の一番外に
あの仏教で我々に言われて
僕によく言われたんですね
玄関のマットのように生活しなくちゃいけないんだと
だから僕の頭にずっともうもう this 刻んでるんです
玄関のマットという例えが
私は何者でもなく ただの玄関のマットですと
人が何言おうが それはもう全然気にしない
あれ それは出家者の道なんです
私は決して完璧じゃないんだから
それ完璧でないことを他人はこの高慢ですか
これはもうなかなかできないんです
慢というのは慢です 慢っていうのは高慢という慢
慢という日本語でしか言葉がない
ですから このカルマの三番目の道は
そういう風に何の目的とか利益ではなくて
心を清らかにするためにやると
なんで慈しみの慈悲の瞑想をするかというと
自分の心に怒りが生まれないように
他人を差別する気持ちが消えてもらうために
慈悲の瞑想する 不浄観の瞑想するんです
なぜかというと 我々人間見ると
この上辺しか 外の殻しか見てないんです
人間の外の殻を見て ああ綺麗な人だ
ああおじいちゃんだ まああまり見たくないんだとかね
そういうふうにすごいことをやってるんです
そこで勝手にあの人綺麗だと思ったら
そこに取らわれちゃうし
綺麗であろうが綺麗でないこと
外だけでしょうに 皮膚を剥いてみたら何のこともないんです
ですから わざと我々仏教では不浄観を瞑想するんです
体は不浄であると 誰の体もある
ですから もうおじいちゃんが来ても
子供が来ても 若い女の子が
娘さんが来ても 全然平気なんです
外の顔は見ない だからそのためにそういう瞑想をするんです
そういうふうに この心に何も取らわれないところを作るんです
そうすると 善行為もしないし
悪い行為もしない心が生まれるんです
悪い行為はもともともしない
まあもともともやめて
それから善行為をしながら善行為のレベルアップするんです
まず まずはみんなに褒めてもらうんだから
いいことをする みんなに認めてくれるんだから
みんな助けてあげたりする
みんなに仰せもする それでどんどんもうやりきれなくなっちゃうんですから
結局 それで次のレベルアップして
自分の欲望を捨てるためにやるんだと
私の心の怒りをなくすために慈悲の瞑想をするんだと
私は人を差別してるんだから
顔を見て あの人は若い
この人若くないとかね
あの人すごい美人だ その人はそうではないとか
頭の中で判断しちゃいますからね
それを消してもらうために不浄観という瞑想があるんです
で それをやると そういうふうに
まあ人を心を育てるんです
育てることによって すべてのカルマから人々に脱出
脱出することができるんです
そこで それだけで足らないんだから
この智慧を発達しなくちゃいけないんですね
智慧を発展するためには
このありとあらゆるヴェール
ヴェールを破らなくちゃいけない
僕はすごい簡単に破れるこの世界のヴェールを最初に言ったんだけど
あれだけでも怖かったんです
私さえでも こんなこと言ってどうなるかとね
もう私は大丈夫なんですけど
みんな心配しちゃったらね
これ私は坊さんとして良くないことやったことになりますけど
まぁとにかくいろいろ心のヴェールを脱いで破っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
それにヴェールが出てくる原因を探さなくちゃいけない
例えば 私はこの部屋を見て
ああ綺麗な部屋だ ああ
東京新宿のなんとか建物だからかなり高いところだ
いろいろ考えちゃうでしょう
ですから そこで我々はわざわざといろんな色目だね
ヴェールを頭の中で作っちゃうんです
で 例えば誰かちょっと鼻を立てているところ見る途端
ああ これはもうなんとか流派の
もうこれはもう もう田中家元のなんとか
ああだこうだとか言っちゃうでしょう
[笑い]そこで我々はいろんな固定概念で
いろんな知識で いろんな哲学で
頭の中でいっぱいベールを作っている
それをまず破ることで智慧が生まれる
そのために見るものは見るもので止まると
これヴィパッサナーで言ってるのはそれなんですね
見たものは綺麗だ 綺麗じゃないと判断するんじゃなくて
見えると 聞こえるものとしては音
あるいは聞こえると 体に何か触れたら
あ 触れましたと それだけで思考をストップしてみるんです
このストップする思考は全部妄想の思考なんです
で してみると心に智慧が現れてくる
智慧が現れるとカルマが消えちゃうんです
だから完全にカルマが消えたという状態は完全に悟ったという状態なんです
そういうことは人間にお釈迦様勧めている道なんです
ですから この怖いことは言ったかもしれませんだけど
まずお釈迦様が言うのは悪いことをやめましょうと
この原文 この前も言ったと思いますけど
パッブバーパッスアカラナ
全ての悪行 悪行 悪行為をしないこと
これがすごい複雑な言葉二つで
あの善行 これは全ての悪行為をやらないこととか言ってるんだから
全ての善行為をすることっても意味じゃなくて
善になることっていうふうな意味なんです
いわゆる善を行ること
クサラっていうのは善
善行為を ウパサンガダっていうのは行うと
あるいは善の人間になると
立派な人間になると 三行目いきます
サチって自分の心をありのままなんてのは掃除しなさいと
清らかにしなさい 心を清めましょう
エータン これはブッダのサーサナ
諸々のブッダたちの教えですよと
お釈迦様一人だけではなくて
まあどんなブッダも教えるのはそれですよと
ですから この輪廻はいくら恐ろしくたっても
まあ我々にとってはまあしょうがないし
我々はその代わりに悪いことはできるだけ
できるだけではなくて
全部やめようとすると
同時にいいことをしようとする
それからいいことをしていると
どんどん頭が良くなって
なんか徳を目指して 御利益を目指していいことをするのはバカバカらしくなっちゃうんです
やっぱりそれはやめて
心を清らかにするためにやりましょうと
というふうな三番 三番目の道で善行為をして悟ると
これは心を清らかにすることなんですね
ですから  ここら辺で話を終了させていただきます